[Music]
you don't have to live with being raped
only thing we're going to a business
meeting I don't see how we can possibly
feed 65 million people in our country
without buying food from abroad I have
no idea what I'm doing so that's kind of
scary Harvey Weinstein was the most
powerful figure in the movie industry a
man who controlled the fortunes and in
many cases livelihoods of scores of
people in Hollywood mr. Thompson was a
28 year old business woman who'd
arranged a meeting at his company well
tonight Sky News can reveal for the
first time what happened at that meeting
with video filmed on miss Thompson's
laptop
how's your day every day I was thinking
okay he's hugging me what what do I do
now I was sensing I have to be a little
bit more vigilant of this situation than
I originally thought
okay sorry but that I won't so what do
you want no it's okay
so I have your higher hand so many
things and you do so many things so I
have a lot of time every time that he
toed the line of being inappropriate
enough where I may have said something
he could sense it and he pulled he
pulled back any changed a dynamic again
let's see I wanted to show a trailer you
mean at my movie
you mean like I mean I have the Marilyn
on Volvo so let's have a Marilyn Monroe
would be people who would be interested
in that movie who would be interested
actually seriously good we can do both
okay so would it be what's target
demographic with me okay so what we're
gonna buy space we're gonna buy ad space
on Volcom do you think you might have
encouraged him i don't think i purposely
encouraged him at first I tried to you
know volley a little bit with him you
know if he would make a comment I would
try to catch it return it in a way that
felt its little safer than the way he
threw it at me now I see he's trying to
in any way you can move me into that
zone of comfortable than uncomfortable
and confused and vulnerable and
recognizing that he's powerful and I'm
not and that I need this deal from him
and he's gonna he has a power to give it
to me we can have like to win two VIP
passes to the premiere in New York and
they have to like it so now you're
generating all these likes on our
Facebook page
Wow okay unanimity is your service okay
I'm Marilyn real good and then you know
you can sign me up so your boss and so
he's going from almost pulling a trigger
on using this platform to then he put
his hand up under the table up my dress
I was trying to save face that at first
I was trying to kind of manage a
situation there was a combination of
confidence and a naivety that led me to
you know this dynamic that we see now do
you so hot so another thing is thinking
is surge I don't know how much you will
know that the surges of the parka movie
with skyrocket to go awesome kind of app
thing I said a by the look where they
wanted to in the trailer they wanted
people to be able to buy her clothing so
they partnered with Outlook and what I
hope you thought of me - I tried to keep
it on script in terms of pitching him
the product but I still touch you on the
shoulder he was still touching me a
stranger in your head as that's
happening I what do i do how did I get
myself here I lost my train of thought
and I was trying so hard to to gain back
my own mental footing at some point his
his whole effect changed and and he
looked like a predator he is his eyes
became dark what would you say to
someone who might water sat and say well
Vanessa was flirting with him
is that what you see when you watch it
it was more tricky than I think it's
possible to judge from looking at it
I've worked on Wall Street before I went
to business school and I worked in an
environment that was heavily
male-dominated I thought I could handle
it I had never met any one that I
couldn't handle until Harvey Weinstein
[Music]
when you go to the kitchen you adjust
the angle of the computer I did why I
knew that I was losing the ability to
control the duration keep it
professional so I had entered that
fight-or-flight mode and I was scared of
him it's 3:30 for each other ground were
you under the impression that that
meeting was to close the deal
potentially yes so it wasn't at 10:00
p.m.
it wasn't an invitation to come to his
hotel room it was invitation to a hotel
lobby that was within blocks of the
office and so that to me felt much safer
than being alone with him in his office
Melissa's business meeting and the
alleged rape a part of a class action
lawsuit against Weinstein and others
connected to him who might have known
what was happening had people been more
vocal and not said yeah that's Harvey or
yeah we have to look at that you don't
you don't have to live with things that
are legal and abusive and and we don't
have to look we don't have to live with
being raped only think we're going to a
business meeting in a statement Harvey
Weinstein's lawyer Benjamin Brafman said
several respected journalists and
trustworthy individuals have seen the
entire video the video when viewed in
its entirety in context and not in
select excerpts demonstrates that there
is nothing forceful but casual if not
awkward flirting from both parties
anything short of that is intended to
make mr. Weinstein appear inappropriate
and even exploitative it was produced by
mr. Thompson to bolster her position in
a civil lawsuit seeking money this is a
further attempt to public
disgraced mr. Weinstein for financial
gain and we will not stand for it facts
do you matter
clock how are you may I ask this because
this time last year you were in a very
dark place you went missing yeah and
we'll pick up with that story at the
moment but but how are you today to have
my song incredibly well thank you
incredibly well yeah I'm you know I
think I am in the most emotionally
psychologically well states that have
been as an adult which is just
incredible not without hard work but
we're there and it's awesome because
you've battled with your mental health
for a number of years and this incident
I'm referring to this time last year
you went missing yeah and your wife put
out an appeal on social media to try and
find you because she thought she would
never see you again
it's I can't you know it's hard for me
to kind of appreciate what what I put my
family through with the decisions that I
made when I was in that state and but
yeah you know what a little bit of
awareness actually saved my life because
instead of just going out and trying to
kill myself I tried to find a
responsible way to kill myself because I
was trying to think about that the
witnesses the first responders you know
the impact on AB&C and it was that
procrastination that enabled a member of
public it seen the social media appeal
to take one minute out of his day and
just come and say hello to me and sit me
down on the park and that's been the
beginning of this year-long journey
where my family and I we've made some
huge strides like I said not without
hard work but with fantastic rewards the
good easiest national statistics show
that male suicide rates are at their
lowest since records began
but o'clock it's still the biggest
killer of men under the age of 45 it's
gonna affect your mental health for the
better to talk about it not to bottle it
up were you talking enough before we got
to that point last September no I wasn't
and in fact you know I'm gonna stick I'm
gonna take that back I was talking but I
wasn't talking honestly enough and
there's a there's a distinct difference
between how are you yeah I'm alright
fella yeah all good happy days and how
are you do you know what just got this
and that going on at home and it's
really making me feel down there's a
distinct difference
you know my wife we wrote an article
last weeks up in Newcastle in the
journal and it's about 84 men will take
their lives next week 84 this week next
week the week after and they're entirely
preventable she makes a fantastic point
they're entirely preventable like Owen
said it's it's about listening you know
and the difference is between what I
used to do and what I do now I talk with
honesty but also when I listen it's not
my responsibility to make this person
better you know I used to think I've got
to fix you I've got to do this for you
I've got to do that for you no no not at
all I used to listen and once I'd listen
I'd say so how can I help you in this
what do you want me to do for you nine
times out of ten that person will say do
you know what nothing thanks for
listening and it takes a huge load off
of what's going on in their mind but
verbalizing what's going on in your mind
decreases the power or the frustration
or the latent thoughts
so much so so much
whatever kind of break to deal is
negotiated if the United Kingdom leaves
the cinema it is likely there will be
some kind of border with the European
Union for business that means red tape
bureaucracy and attention logjams why do
we say that well our Europe
correspondent Mark Stone has been out on
the road with the delivery driver to see
how Switzerland
I'm never like I'm never late
straight down bid the front through the
Montblanc
that's sure in towards my land and and
down the bottom leg towards Rome just in
time what does that mean just-in-time
deliveries obviously it's in trucks and
vans it will literally come off your van
and straight on to the production line
once you put a barrier up in the middle
of that operation it no longer City no
longer it's called a just-in-time
movement you sound like a right old
pessimist just being factual I've been
doing it for 15 years I've crossed every
border I've invited many many MPs to
come on a job with me to come and see
what it's like how it works
not a Swiss job just a job to come out
of London to go to France to experience
what it means to have open borders for
commercial goods and not one of them
wants to come with me
it will gridlock from day one it would
take a decade to build the of more than
a decade to build the necessary
infrastructure that this country needs
all the salad that comes in from the
Netherlands the oranges the cucumbers
that come from the greenhouses of
Almeria
all come in on trucks to meet the
supermarket shelves to make sure they're
not empty we can grow our own food I
don't see how we can possibly feed 65
million people in our country without
buying food from abroad we can't grow
oranges anyway like quite a lot oranges
it's true though we don't have the
climate but this is all this is all
project fear people will say you're just
it's never gonna it's never going to
come to pass they'll only realize when
it's happened to not be talking to you
for so long I've forgot to book my train
[Music]
today marks the 17th anniversary of the
September the 11th 2001 terror attacks
9/11 in which almost 3,000 people were
killed here
the annual BGC charity day it will be
remembering the 658 colleagues and 61
Yura broker employees of that financial
company who were lost in the world trade
central 9/11 it will raise money for a
number of charities celebrities a range
of celebrities actually assisting
brokers in making multi-million pound
deals that speak to one of them who's
joining the fundraising effort that's
the singer Nicole Scherzinger what are
your memories of that day and are you
sure that we're remembering it in the
right way now you know talk to teenagers
recently and mentioned 9/11 to them and
they scarcely knew what I was talking
about I mean I can't and I can't imagine
a better way actually to remember it in
fact I just flew here a few hours ago
from New York City so I remember that
day like it was yesterday
and I remember watching everything
unfold and happen in front of me on TV
and it was such a a tragic tragic day so
I couldn't I'm so proud to be here right
now raising awareness for our cause
making the world a better place in some
way giving back so I think it's great a
great way to honor and remember the
people who were lost tell us what you're
doing there today I'm here representing
the Special Olympics I'm here to raise
money and awareness for them and
practically how will you raise money are
you actually making deals you cold
calling people tapping them to cash how
does it work actually it is like
honestly it's like a zoo here I've never
done anything like this I'm actually on
the phone making trades
I'm just spouting off numbers I've just
learned that a yard is a billion so like
we're just making a lot of money and
that's what I love people want to make
big deals big numbers sounds like you're
in danger of precipitating a new
financial crisis I'd like that I have no
idea what I'm doing so that's kind of
scary but I think we're doing good I
think we've raised a lot of money today
how much do they hope to raise how much
we hope to raise I mean
150,000 150,000 Oh 150 million today
yeah I've already raised that a couple
hours ago this morning
[Laughter]
[Music]
what are we to be done
[Applause]
ever since it's been announced you hope
you have a good week but just to top it
off obviously with her the score here
was just like incredible like sometimes
dreams do come true and I suppose today
on a purely selfish thing and then even
just fielding at a short leg you know
with the crowd singing what the Barney
Army song it's just you know it's what
it's what you play your sport I suppose
occasionally for those little selfish
moments and that was very special it was
emotional my own grave mate I mean
there's definitely lump in my throat I
mean that ovation and it makes it
special obviously I've got about thirty
friends here today and actually some
obviously family as well it's just you
could just we couldn't script actually
today it's just one of those days where
you know you're forever look back and
just thinking wow what will you miss the
dressing room obviously I see my little
statement I said oh you know playing
with some great players
I will obviously miss that setting and
they change them but the timings right
and it is right it just makes this even
more special and they just threw such a
nice way for me personally
[Applause]
now there's a musical genre that was
forgotten for a while but the success of
films like pitch-perfect has made a
cappella call the game the last famous
British a cappella group with a flying
picky and super forget who had a
Christmas number one in those days its
release some of people will not remember
them only you
[Music]
well there is now and I cappella group
taking the world by storm that don't
have the sideburns but they are selling
more tickets for their live shows than
any other acapella group in the world
Straight No Chaser are the only a
cappella group to have worked with I've
recorded with some legendary artists the
lightest II wonder sale John Paul
McCartney and many others besides
[Applause]
[Music]
I was trying to get conversation dad
dancing but all he did was tap a speech
well straight no chaser have taken time
out from there to join us live in the
studio this morning thank you very much
chair it's really lovely to have you
here Charlie to you first of all and why
do you think I cappella hasn't been so
popular in recent years and it's
suddenly you guys have got this
resurgence I think it kind of seemed
like kind of a dorky music genre we
started this group really to meet girls
and in college so it's the best
icebreaker
you know women love guys who can sing
and none of us can play guitar that well
so singing was just the natural fit I
just chose a mechanics of how you got to
where you are now you had some campus at
University yes but the big thing that
Lord she was YouTube yeah absolutely we
we left the group at Indiana University
it still exists there are still kids in
that group every year new kids
we left it on its own and we went and
did day jobs all over the country and
then because of YouTube we got a call
from Atlantic Records do you guys still
sing together and we were like because
they can cuz you're 12 days of Christmas
on YouTube oh yeah 2020 old million
people saw it and the thing that's
staggering about it we've all tried to
sing rounds at Christmas time haven't we
but how did you manage that sort of
contrapuntal is the word isn't when
you're singing against each other how do
you keep a lot of rehearsal it's a lot
harder than it sounds and we make it
look fun and easy but that took a lot of
work
[Music]
this is Skyy knees radio on Friday the
14th of September production of one of
the world's most iconic cars is to end
next year
I have squeezed myself into this old
beetle I'm joined by Ivan McCutcheon as
well an expert in cars like this so tell
us a little bit about this car
this is a 1961 version its barrel green
which is a very typical color of the
early 60s is right-hand drive which is
obviously quite rare now and it's still
going strong and in terms of the history
of this car it's been going 70 odd years
has it remind us of its founding the
beetle was first introduced into Germany
in 1938 by a group of guys who we won't
talk about too much
it was Adolphe hitler wasn't it it was
his group yes yes and but he didn't
actually start until after the war
production of the car which was down to
the British Army why don't we attempt to
get this thing going hey it works
reliable doing my best here let's see if
we can get this thing moving hey we're
going no stalling either it actually
handles quite well a bit a bit bit tough
on the steering Ivan it's a yeah a
little bit
we already doing about full of miles an
hour hey we've got us no safe we've got
to Stacey
[Music]